hi I'm Eric Vossen of interest in games
celebrated its Internet breaking opening
day of ticket sales with a new trailer
oh you know just a 1 minute special look
that's somehow reveals more from the
movie the past full-length trailers
combined you trust me
I do yeah I don't
the directors warned us that this promo
footage could be CGI trickery to keep us
guessing so as I break down this trailer
frame by frame for all the details that
you might have missed I'm gonna be on
high alert for the stuff that might be
faked they're not fooling us this time
Russo's spoiler warning in case they
accidentally predict anything great ruin
your life let's get started
if we do this we'd be going in
short-handed yeah you mean cuz he killed
all that front we owe this to everyone
who's not in this room to try
okay this trailer opens with an exterior
shot of Avengers HQ this is the same
gate that Scott Lang showed up at in
security camera footage in the first
endgame trailer this could be that
moment he arrives having recently
escaped from the quantum realm somehow
and let's not forget that footage was
labeled archive suggesting that we could
be looking at some kind of timeline
Medlin inside Bruce Banner and the other
Avengers debate taking another shot at
danos in the aftermath of the snap and
other videos have suggested that the
first act of endgame could feature some
rushed payback attempt by the Avengers
and it could actually make their
situation a lot worse another failure to
further humiliate them by we'd be going
in short-handed banner could be implying
that in addition to half their fighters
he's also still experiencing Hulk
performance anxiety bringing up the
question when will the whole comeback
could he be in semi-intelligent
professor Hulk form let me know in the
comments below what you think the
trigger moment will be meanwhile for
carbs up with a bowl of what looks like
Kings Hawaiian sweet rolls and a can of
beer zoom in Hansel that bad boy and you
could see it's an Athena from the
creature comforts brewery in Athens
Georgia not far from the Atlanta
Pinewood Studios lot where these movies
are filmed I imagine a lot of the actors
and crew people like drinking from this
local brewery I just hope this whole sob
fest ends with Thor shotgunning the beer
crushing it shouting another there's
also a shot of natasha moping in the
rain and judging from the official black
widow hair clock it's looking mostly red
with the blonde being flushed out of the
tips suggesting that this is after other
events when her hair is shorter and
blonder meaning this moping could be
after some early loss and our other hair
clock is the rug on CAPS face and in the
shot of him at the mirror he appears to
have just shaved the rug meaning that
this could be even earlier before some
act 1 mission let's move on it's not
about how much we lost it's about how
much we have left
[Music]
wizzy ventures
we gotta finish this
okay a quick shot of a Quinjet over
tokyo that we've seen before is it
probably Natasha going to Japan to find
Hawkeye then a shot of rocket holding
nebulas hand showing that a waste of
parts can feel there on the ramp at the
Benatar and judging from the shot of
pepper hugging Tony this could be the
moment that Tony and nebula returned to
Earth they could be what Kat Natasha
banner and Rhodey and digitally removed
character we're looking up at on the
lawn digitally removed character or just
Drax standing very still Karen Gillan
hinted months ago that she would have a
new BFF an end game and it looks like
rocket is her new shoulder to cry on
it's especially sad when you consider
that this is the moment when the two
surviving guardians of the galaxy
learned about the casualties on the
other side like nebula is realizing
Groot has dusted and rocket is realizing
quill Gamora mantis and Drax are all
gone these two aren't really known for
physical affection but Rockets
heartbreak leads him to reach out in a
very similar way that Drax reached out
to consult him at the end of the first
guardians then there's a shot of Iron
Man and his new mark 85 armor it's
thicker and its shoulders arms and legs
are gold coloured similar to Iron Man's
throwback classic armor and the Silver
Age comics but I'm more curious about
the context of this scene Iron Man is
flying high enough that he's probably up
near Avengers tower also the background
of New York looks bright relatively
normal a definite contrast with the
dreary apocalyptic Manhattan that we saw
in past trailers it's covered in the
dust of Mets fans there's also the fact
that Iron Man's armor is the mark 85
like the last suit we saw was the mark
50 the sleek nanotech suit that he worn
infinity Wars oh why is Tony iPhone X
eNOS to me this brings me back to the
timeline Medlin theory suggesting that
the Avengers will use some quantum
technology maybe to change the timeline
and revisit past MCU moments like the
Battle of New York in the first Avengers
movie so we could be seeing stark
reliving his moment with Selvig and Loki
at the top of Avengers Tower in that
battle but another angle on this theory
is that the adventures could already be
in a time loop established by Doctor
Strange one that will require them to
lose up to over 14 million times until
they figure out the one sequence of
history in which they beat Thanos this
could justify the movie's 3 hour runtime
and why Tony would have burned through
so many generations of Iron Man
armored I liked this theory I think I'll
go into it more in a future video
there's also a shot of Clint Barton
Hawkeye his arm is now covered with the
sleeve tattoo let's zoom in enhance on
this fine print you could definitely
make out a skill inside Japanese warrior
armor this reflects Clint's new role as
Ronin the Japanese lone warrior from
Marvel Comics the skull could symbolize
how he's dead inside perhaps from seeing
his party of five dust down into a party
of one during this footage we hear the
voice of Tony Stark was he's injured we
can finish this now audio in general and
trailers is almost always manipulated
dubbed in from other scenes but Tony's
more tears sound especially familiar
that's because his weird The Avengers is
actually the exact audio lifted from his
line in Avengers age of Ultron with
Avengers risky ventures and this was an
especially significant moment to call
back to because listen to the full clip
with Avengers we can bust arms to which
all the live long day but that up there
that's that's in game that's right this
was the first time the word end game
came up as stark warned about cosmic
threats like Thanos also people were
telling me that the German version of
this trailer features Tony saying a
different lion in the scene I told you
we would lose but you said we would do
that together which would also be a
callback to the final exchange of the
same scene an Ultron will lose then
we'll do that together too now I know
the Russos admitted to using footage and
audio from past films for these trailers
but I have a feeling that this age of
Ultron moment wasn't a coincidence but I
will also dig in this more in that other
video there's a shot of Natasha followed
by a new angle of Thor's summoning
Stormbreaker passing unflinching Captain
Marvel doesn't even blink and then this
solemn group shot of the survivors and
Avengers HQ are all together
Hawkeye Rhodey stark cap nebula rocket
Scott Lang and Natasha but I gotta say
this shot just looks really posed to me
everyone's standing facing the same
direction with the same bland look on
their faces like there's a goddamn
Backstreet Boys I'm sure they could be
facing other characters not in this
angle like the war in Captain Marvel
just saying on the other side of the
room maybe or maybe this is from the end
of the movie and all the dusted are
fading back into the timeline like
notice on Natasha is holding our
shoulder like she saw or
did like after a fight but yeah my
instinct is telling me that this whole
lineup could just be the end game
equivalent of that whole group jog from
the infinity war trailer that ended up
not being in the movie but let's move on
to the next clip you trust me I do
you could not live with your own failure
okay let's dig into a lad named Jasmine
here Stark and cap appear to be in New
York maybe even the Battle of it you can
see emergency lights in the background
and as sweet as it is to see these two
frenemies finally shake hands and make
up something definitely seems off about
it I'm about to throw up all over it
look at cap he appears to be wearing his
dark blue torn suit that he had an
infinity war which would be a little odd
because in other shots cap wears his
winter soldier stealth suit also another
suit that looks a bit new maybe a bit
retro now some are saying the shot of a
handshake could be a different character
but I think we're just seeing a
different cap and this could be some of
that CGI trickery that the Russos were
talking about just look at his suit
again it looks a bit off the scales are
kind of different the surfaces are
smoother a bit more rubbery and that
strap buckle could be a feature on a
ready player one avatar may be Marvel's
VFX artist painted this infinity war-era
suit over a different cap suit and if we
are talking timeline Medlen stark could
be talking to a younger Captain America
who remember did have a much brighter
suit during the Battle of New York stark
could be trying to convince him to trust
this much older Tony Stark to help this
old man grab both the tesseract and
Loki's scepter because it's old crazy
start from the futures babbling on out
there actually Infinity stones he needs
to erase them from history Gandhi trust
me right I do there's actually another
possible clue of this whole theory in
the next shot showing the Bennet are
jumping into Lightspeed
now you can barely make out a few people
sitting in the back seats of that
cockpit but actually take a closer look
at what planet they're departing now
before I assume this could just be Tony
and nebula finally figuring out how to
jumpstart the benitar and return to
Earth but that purplish planet behind
them with the multiple moons that looks
a lot like Morag the abandoned planet at
the beginning of the first guardians of
the galaxy why is Morag important well
the temple on this planet was the
resting place of the orb containing the
power stone before Peter quill removed
it so in the same way that the surviving
Avengers could revisit the events of the
first Avengers movie to retrieve those
Infinity stones they might do the same
with the events of guardians of the
galaxy in all of the past Marvel films
that featured the stones now this shot
of the benatar cuts to a different shot
of the same
featuring rocket and Captain Marvel and
the pilot and co-pilot seats cap Thor
roadie and Natasha I think nebula might
be somewhere back there too but check it
in with our hair clock Black Widow still
has it's short and blond suggesting that
this would take place shortly after the
events of the snap and shortly after
they team up with Captain Marvel early
on in the film so like notice how banner
and Tony are not joining them suggesting
that this might be a haphazard assault
that the more intellectual Avengers
might prefer to sit out and back this
group so trigger-happy that poor doesn't
even bother to wear a seat belt oh maybe
he's like Drax and his sensitive nipples
actually think that this is the mission
that CAPA Natasha were embarking on in
the first endgame trailer the desperate
one that Steve wouldn't know what to do
if it failed and we see a possible
destination for that mission here with
the shot of Thanos his ship the
sanctuary - surrounded by various cue
ships notice the red lights on that ship
they could be the same red lights that
lit the tunnel that Hawkeye appeared in
in the last trailer the one that we've
realized recently was filled without
writers assuming that some of the
Avengers do try to strike back against
Thanos in the first act I don't really
feel good about all of them coming back
alive especially Captain Marvel we've
seen her alive and Avengers HQ and
co-piloting the [ __ ] but that's it the
early loss of the Avengers biggest
ace-in-the-hole could plunge their rock
bottom even lower and make their
eventual victory over Thanos hopefully
that much more earned there's also a
shot of stark looking at this photo of
him in Peter Parker and it looks like
they're holding Peters Stark Industries
certificate may be the one that start
told Aunt May that Peter won in order to
discreetly recruit him back in Civil War
but notice how they're holding it upside
down now the bar behind Tony looks a
little similar to his penthouse bar the
one that was a top of interest tower
also the shirt he's wearing kind of
looks like his Black Sabbath shirt that
he was also wearing during that
confrontation with Loki which if they do
revisit it in this movie would be
another interesting moment that
foreshadowed the events to come and the
MCU if we can't protect the Earth could
be damn well sure we'll avenge it let's
move on to the final clip where did that
bring you
[Music]
back to me
okay here there's a quick shot of Thor
in a similar location to where we saw
him in the Super Bowl promo but then
there's this interesting shot of rocket
look at the pattern on the floor behind
him it looks a lot like the pattern on
the floor if they a nurse's throne room
in the sanctuary to which we saw in that
scene between Thanos and Gamora here
rocket looks particularly sad notice
also the sparks that float past him like
I'm wondering if he's witnessing the
fiery death of one of his companions or
maybe he has an emotional reaction to
fan OHS for a different reason Rockets
origin is still very much a mystery his
bio-data and Guardians Volume one listed
his home planet as half world but he was
cybernetically engineered by some cruel
scientist and the movies have never
established who that was one theory that
I brought it before is that it could
have been phantoms and that rocket could
be one of the children of Thanos I
couldn't be why rocket chose to go with
Thor to help him get his new god-killer
weapon instead of facing thinest
directly with the other guardians in a
deleted scene set in Thanos's throne
room Thanos uses the reality stone to
project a memory in which Gamora served
as a loyal child of Thanos maybe endgame
will feature a similar flashback in the
setting for rocket but except there's
this shot of cap struggling on the
ground with his classic shield this
could be right before he gets to his
feet and tightens his strap that we've
seen in the other shots now overall this
footage the voice of Thanos rings out
taunting us you could not live on with
your own failure and where did that
bring you back to me the exact words of
every pizza box says it flaps open as
they go back for another piece and we
finally see the mad Titan here but there
are two interesting details about him in
the shot first he's back in his armor
remember if Thanos removed his battle
armor at the beginning of infinity war
because once he acquired the power stone
and the space stone getting the final
stones was more of a spiritual quest for
him than one that he needed to
physically fight through seeing him back
in his armor now suggests that he feels
threatened that he's afraid of getting
hurt that he's worried that he has
something to lose but there's another
clue that he might not have the full
power of the Infinity Gauntlet way he
arrives with the space stone Thanos
could open a wormhole a portal in space
and teleport wherever he wanted but now
it's different
he beams in now some are describing this
as the Bifrost that Thor uses to get
around but I don't think this is the
Bifrost the Bifrost is a rainbow II
color to it this beam is pure blue
actually this is exactly how we saw
the black order beamed down from the
queue ship the fact that thinness has to
do this along with its need to wear
armor suggests that the Avengers that
probably made some headway at getting at
least some of the stones away from him
then we see stark in his Iron Man armor
walking among some smokey rebel it looks
like the same battlefield as the one
that we saw cap and the others fighting
on the trailers money shot joins him
with cap and Thor Marvel Trinity as they
marched upon Thanos you can see him
sitting in the background there perhaps
a bit similar to the way Doctor Strange
did as he waited for Thanos on Titan but
was really setting the trap for him
beside Thanos is his new weapon a
double-sided sword blade thingy that we
saw in concept art and in some toy
releases it's there's always in the toys
and people closely could see up Diana's
hung his helmet on top of that but where
is this battle taking place the rubble
looks like some construction scaffolding
meaning this is probably somewhere on
earth and it looks like there will be
one battle scene set at Avengers HQ
suggesting that Thanos could attack the
facility as the Avengers start to make
progress against him but another theory
that a lot of you have brought up to me
is that if we are looking at a replay of
the Battle of New York timeline Medlin
this Medlin could lead to a ripple
effect in which that nuke that was fired
at the city rather than being carried up
to the wormhole by Iron Man and thrown
at the Chitauri could instead detonate
over New York and reduce the city to
rubble and if you're looking for a high
stakes backdrop for the Avengers final
confrontation with Thanos the ashes of
New York City is a pretty bleak option
then again folks all this footage is
rumored to just be from the first act of
the movie and the Russo's might have
just CGI'd all of it to screw with us so
comment down below with your favorite
moment from this trailer follow me on
Instagram and on Twitter at EA boss hey
and if you plan to go to VidCon this
year please tweet at VidCon to let them
know that you'd love to see us in a
panel a live show a meet-and-greet so
that we can thank you guys in person for
all of your support and if you live in
the LA area you can come check out my
live comedy show darkest timeline comedy
with me mod Philip and Sam this Friday
April 5th and every first Friday of the
month thereafter ticket info in the
description below and if you consider
yourself a nerd you gotta be there
because I didn't spend a hundred bucks
on this and wear it for the entire video
for nothing snap
[Music]